well when I was working at Jesse James
one of the big questions that surrounds
Jesse James life is was he an anti
railroad Robin Hood the classic
mythology surrounding him states that he
was so I looked at the question of
questions related to the financial
system during his lifetime during and
after the Civil War the railroad system
and found some really interesting things
for example when Jesse James Rob trains
he wasn't robbing railroad companies he
was robbing Express companies which
rented space in baggage cars for the
messengers and safes and they
transported cash for banks along with
valuables and other expensive high
priority shipments well farmers didn't
deal with Express companies they dealt
with railroads in shipping their crops
and they did resent railroads but they
didn't care about Express companies
railroads didn't care about Jesse James
but expressed companies did and then
getting into the question of well why is
all this cash being shipped around the
country looking into the financial
system and so this early investigation
of the economic questions of the 19th
century the rise the railroad the rise
of the corporation the rise of the
modern financial system emerged very
organically out of my work on Jesse
James and it was really interesting and
I couldn't explore it in Jesse James and
keep my book being about Jesse James so
I thought this is a great way to go with
my next book and then the question
became okay so I have these these
questions I have these topics the rise
of the corporation the rise of the
railroad who's who's an interesting
person whose life speaks to those
questions someone preferably who has not
been written about too much before and
Cornelius Vanderbilt presented himself
he was called a railroad king of the
19th century America and yet the last
really serious biography of him was
published in 1942 and it's necessarily
dated it's very good for its time but
you know it's time has passed so you
know Vanderbilt was not just a
bookkeeper who
took to investing in railroads again he
was a very physically dramatic figure
and so he attracted me in terms of the
storytelling as well as the the big
questions that defined his life
I spent almost seven years on the first
icon and I learned why there had not
been a serious biography since nineteen
forty-two no one hated himself enough to
undertake the task it was this process
of finding sources that had never been
connected to Vanderbilt before he left
no collection of papers behind he did
not leave behind this manuscript
collection the the Vanderbilt papers and
for that reason historians and
biographers have sort of steered clear
of him he shows up in books about other
subjects there are no books about him
virtually so I'd like to say often that
historians are rather like the story of
the the drunk who he drives home and
pulls up into his driveway and gets out
he drops his keys by the car and his
wife comes out and finds him on the
porch on his hands and knees and she
asked what he's doing he explains she
says why aren't you on the driveway
looking for your keys so the lights
better here and historians often will
write about subjects who are not as
significant as others but there's a big
collection of papers is there's a big
manuscript archive they can work in that
makes the job easier and more satisfying
and more complete and they'll leave
sometimes avoid someone like Vanderbilt
who is incredibly significant and yet he
left note simple archive so the process
began with going through for example
that 1942 biography finding out what we
do know exists starting with that then
starting to go off on tangents and to
think about who else is connected to
this person's life who else might have
collections of papers there are you know
manuscript catalogs that are available
and again that the process of
digitization began to pay benefits first
with putting online the catalogs of
manuscript collections being able to
know what is where then finding out
about sources related to company
is that he was involved in you know
pursuing the tangents and then giving
myself time to get lucky as the process
essentially and then finally there's the
immense transformation of digitization
and this appears primarily not in
manuscript material letters and diaries
and whatnot but in newspapers in public
records and there are for the most part
proprietary companies that have been
scanning newspapers and other documents
and have been making them available with
with character recognition software so
you can search them and but these are
only available through major research
libraries so a lot of my time is spent
on site in research libraries going
through these doing text searches for
Vanderbilt and other related words and
actually the power of digitization
actually adds time to the process
because you pull up so many hits and
some of them are false leads I found out
there was a lot of property for sale on
vanderbilt avenue in brooklyn in the
19th century and some of them are hits
that are redundant you know 10
newspapers have basically the same
report about the same thing and there's
nothing new there and yet i would have
to go through each one in case there's
some nugget that i've missed so the very
power of digitization has actually made
research more laborious in a sense both
more convenient but also the sheer
amount of material means that the
process actually takes longer if you're
going to be thorough